many legal experts in the u.s predicted
this outcome
the supreme court dismissed a bid by the
state of texas to overturn the
presidential election results
much to the anger of donald trump who
tweeted
the supreme court really let us down no
wisdom
no courage trump and his republican
allies wanted the court to set aside
results in four states won by
president-elect joe biden
georgia michigan pennsylvania and
wisconsin
republican attorney generals and 126
republican members of congress
supported the lawsuit but in a short
statement the court said that texas
has not demonstrated a judicially
cognizable interest in the manner in
which another state
conducts its elections biden's team
celebrated the decision
saying the supreme court has decisively
and speedily rejected the latest of
donald trump and his allies attacks
on the democratic process this is no
surprise
dozens of judges election officials from
both parties
and trump's own attorney general have
dismissed his baseless attempts
to deny he lost the election trump and
other republican organizations have
brought more than 50 lawsuits in various
states
they've achieved partial success in only
one
but legal analysts say trump may
continue to try to overturn the election
results
i don't count them out for trying to
just do something else even though it
probably won't get anywhere because it
is over as of monday when the electoral
college meets but
we cannot be in the head of donald trump
to think what he might try to do next
but this was really his last hail mary
critics of trump say his refusal to
concede defeat has damaged the integrity
of the u.s electoral process
and biden's victory will be officially
certified by the electoral college next
week
victoria gatenbee al jazeera well let's
dig into this with scott lucas he's the
co-founder of america unfiltered
a news and analysis site on u.s politics
and foreign policy he joins us now
from birmingham in the uk scott great to
have you back on al jazeera there's
obviously plenty to unpick here
i want to start with the state of play
does this court order secure
monday's electoral college vote and does
that finally mean the end of this
well as your correspondent noted uh
donald trump's head could lead us
anywhere in the next few weeks but in
terms of trying to prevent joe biden
getting into the white house
it's done you have the combination of
the supreme court which twice in the
past few days
first on tuesday in a case brought over
pennsylvania
then in the texas lawsuit not only
rejected
the trump camps attempts to overturn the
elections they said
there's no way we're going to consider
this there's absolutely no standing here
and you combine that with the political
which is the electoral college meets on
monday
they will confirm joe biden's victory of
306 electors to 232
and that's it it's done what does trump
do next
he then looks ahead probably saying
he'll run for president
the uh the presidency in 2024 to reclaim
what is rightfully his
how much support does he get from the
republican party and from his supporters
to go for this for another four years
well i would just want to come back to
the supreme court decision itself
it was handed down einstein in a very
brief
order is the supreme court even with its
very conservative makeup now
are they trying to send a message here
well they sent a legal message and the
legal message was
that in this specific case seven of the
nine justices said texas
you've got no right to try to interfere
over the way that elections were
conducted in georgia wisconsin
pennsylvania and michigan these four key
states that voted for joe biden
and the two most conservative justices
samuel lolito and clarence thomas said
okay we would consider your case but
there's absolutely no chance
that we would grant you what you want
which is to throw out
the elections in those four states so
this was comprehensive
what is important beyond the supreme
court decision
is the political message and that is in
57
of 58 cases the courts have said
almost immediately you really shouldn't
be here to the trump lawyers
they said there's no claims of fraud
there's no evidence and your legal
theory is completely inappropriate
and misguided well given the political
context let's talk about the republican
party now
18 states more than 100 republicans in
congress
endorsed this i know mitch mcconnell for
instance had been calling for due
process
but where does due process end and where
to for the republican party
when all the smoke finally clears
well let's be very clear first of all
donald trump doesn't care about due
process
donald trump cares about hanging onto
the oval office
and when you had 126 of the 196
republican house members
and when you had 18 state attorney
generals that went along with this
they were quite happy to defy the
american system
now here comes the big challenge once
joe biden becomes president
does someone like the senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
continue to ally himself with the
trumpest
to try to tear down biden even if that
might tear down the us system
or does mitch mcconnell and other
republican leaders finally cut
themselves away from donald trump and
say look
we once were a party that had economic
and social policies
that worked within the rules do they go
back to this
or do we see the trumpist effectively
taking over the gop
well scott then let me ask you the big
question that the entire u.s democratic
process
rests on the perceived legitimacy of
these elections so
where does this whole saga leave that
well i said before the elections this
was the most important american
moment since 1945 and the end of world
war ii
it still is you know the question of
whether this system which has stood for
almost 250 years continues to function
is in the balance
but you will headline quite rightly
those people that support trump that
will go out on the streets that will
spread disinformation
that will shout hoax on the other side
we have a new government
a biden administration if it can get
control of the pandemic that has killed
almost 300
000 americans if it can provide for an
economy which has been bashed this year
if it can provide for social justice for
all americans not for some
well results talk and that's the big
hope that the american system has
is competence and responsibility versus
donald trump's twitter feed
scott lucas there from america
unfiltered always great to keep your
thoughts here on al jazeera thanks for
being with us again scott
thank you